hey folks i'm lucy and welcome to
another episode of good news gaming the
show that highlights all the good and
fun stuff from the week in games just
like these two old Halo three buddies
who met up randomly in a game of Valor
--nt after years of not talking in the
good news this week huge props to both
Sony and Microsoft over the last week
gamers out reach a charity that provides
kids in hospitals with consoles and
games have had more requests for their
portable gaming parts which both go kart
is very good than ever before in their
history the Gears of War team at the
Coalition has made an absolutely huge
and generous donation of 200 X Box 1x
consoles to the program and has also
made a custom gliese 5 scanner vailable
to buy with proceeds going towards
gamers outreach the console donation
alone can facilitate almost 600,000 play
sessions for kids so that's such an
incredible thing that they've done the
link is in the description below if you
want to get that skin and help donate to
the cause meanwhile Sony has launched a
brand new initiative called play at home
which has two missions number one give
people free games so they're entertained
and occupied during social distancing
that to establish a 10 million dollar
fund for Indies who may be struggling
financially during this time free from
now until May 5th our journey and the
Nathan Drake collection on ps4 so really
it's actually four free games and like I
said last week if your PlayStation Plus
subscriber you can get Uncharted 4 for
free too so you can pretty much play all
of the Nathan drink saga but not last
legacy that's not free but you should
get that one it's great anyway what I'm
saying Goforth an adventure stay at home
any hoot it's my favorite pun in Animal
Crossing
blathers has got himself some
competition the Monterey Bay Aquarium
which I'm kind of ashamed that I only
know from big la lies but whatever is
doing virtual tours inside Animal
Crossing they're streaming them like on
Twitch all the while chatting about
fossils dinosaurs and all the fish in
the game they joined forces with Emily
graslie from Chicago's Field Museum
and the streams have a pretty fun and
educational so give it a whirl
I've been completely wrapped up in Final
Fantasy 7 remake this week so I
absolutely had to include this video of
aerith's voice actress Breanna white
hearing herself in the game for the
first time my Ron Final Fantasy 7 remake
reddit user green Indies mum absolutely
crushed this cosplay I wanted to give a
shout out to Dan from our design team
for this next story because he
challenged his neighbor's kid Leo to a
Pokemon battle in the coolest way
possible Leo accepted and the battle
took place but unfortunately for Dan it
looks like he may have accidentally
challenged a Pokemon master in training
because Leo absolutely wiped the floor
with him
I'm looking forward to the rematch I'm
team Leo a bittersweet one now but I
wanted to include it because I think
it's an incredible way of showing just
how powerful video games can be bringing
people together under exceptionally
difficult and sad circumstances
unfortunately a member of the Final
Fantasy 14 community he went by the name
fern the Roy and played on the Solaris
server passed away from complications
due to Cove in 19 so players from all
around the world came together for a
memorial March and you can see the video
right now it's quite spectacular it
feels really weird to sort of transition
away from such a sad story like that and
I obviously kind of don't want to dwell
on it I don't know that person but I
just thought what the community did was
really nice for them so let's let's get
move on uh and kind of end on some on
some happy and outs so here's some of
the Deaf gangs that I really enjoyed
from games this week first up this
incredible Nintendo switch pond which a
I can't believe I've never heard before
and B I kind of felt like a real
disturbance in the force we're just all
the dads kind of put their hands on
their hips and just went
because it's a peak it's an elite tier
dad joke honestly I thought we peaked in
animal crossing creations last week with
that mother recreation but after seeing
this Pokemon one I'm gonna have to keep
my options open the way they use cut to
get rid of the tree is absolutely
perfect and the creator Hina pica has
also included all their codes on their
YouTube channel link obviously below if
you want to download any of the designs
for yourself
I want that Snorlax I'm gonna put him
everywhere I thought resident evil 3 was
scary enough okay but it turns out no
there's a way to make it even more
terrifying and that's to put all the
facial animations up to five hundred
percent horrifying but also as created
DPO 23 pointed out it's even more
horrifying when you realize just how
much Carlos looks like Brendan Fraser
from The Mummy
all right a quick couple things to look
out for over the next few days that's
gonna be a games done quick for co-ed
relief now games done quick is an
incredible initiative they raise so much
money for charity and they are doing a
short one a speedrun for kovat relief it
starts this Friday April 17th and runs
all weekend I'm definitely looking out
for the kingdom hearts 2 final mix run
because they are always wild I'll put a
link to the schedule below so if you're
watching this on Friday finish watching
this and then go watch games done quick
and there's another cool thing you
should be looking out for but I'll let
someone else tell you about that
thanks Lucy yeah it's me Greg Miller
from kind of funny and I'm a proud
graduate of the University of Missouri
and a proud cancer survivor so when the
American Cancer Society reached out to
me and said do you want to represent
Mizzou in our College streaming
tournament I said yes I would love your
support if you could head over to kinda
funny dot-com / Mizzou toss in a few
bucks support the American Cancer
Society they do a lot of great work they
took care of me when I got sick it would
mean a lot to me and go Tigers
alright that's if you can use gaming
this week as usual if you have stories
suggestions leave them in the comments
below
tweet them at me or if you want to join
our discord we have a good news gaming
channel DM me on Twitter for an invite
we're obviously not opening discs or
doctors yet invite-only it's also just
because we don't want it to be overrun
we have a really great community
everyone's really welcoming love talking
about games music photography like we
have channels for everything it's super
cool so if you want to join hit me up
hope your weeks going well hope you're
all staying safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]